Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Lino. Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich verleihe dir hiermit den Lokbuchnetz Politik Award für besondere Leistungen im Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik eins, vier, neun und äh ihr merkt schon, hier wird Einsatz belohnt. Hier wird wir.
Ja, indem wir einfach mal zwanzig Folgen überspringen. Eins, vier, neun.
Wieso? Ach so, eins, zwei, neun, Entschuldigung, ich war in Gedanken bei der Flickshow, die ist heute nämlich auch noch dran.
Und ich habe kurz überlegt, welches äh welches äh Zahlensystem das jetzt ist.
Ja, nee, stimmt, äh eins, zwo, neun, lasst euch nicht äh verunsichern, schon gar nicht von mir. Äh ich vergebe ja nur Awards und Awards vergibt, der hat sie wahrscheinlich eh nicht alle beisammen.
Also was ich natürlich gerade bekommen habe, war der der Timo Online Award.
Genau, da sollte man vielleicht mal wirklich jetzt mal langsam mal anfangen irgendwie für so für so besondere Katastrophenkurse, die eingeschlagen werden, einfach den passenden Award zu vergeben. Ich finde das immer ganz unterhaltsam in der Nord News Show, so was Frank und Fefe sich dann immer wieder für lustige Worts einfallen lassen,
Ich kriege das jetzt nicht so zusammen, aber so, du weißt schon, was ich meine, ne?
Ja ja klar, also was was ist das so.
Irgendwie.
Der.
Josef Josef, der Wort für besondere Leistungen, sozialen Miteinander oder irgendwie sowas. Genau, oder der Award für.
Infrastruktur für.
Besonders soziale Grundeinstellungen. Ja, ja.
Ja, das äh neues Jahr und überall ploppen schon wieder irgendwie die Awards äh hervor, so wie wie die Blümchen im Frühling, ist ganz lustig.
Jetzt muss ich sagen, der der Maggie Fetcher Award für ähm,
Für Infrastruktur, Rückbau, ja? Inspektor Clueso Award für herausragende Polizeiarbeit und sowas. Und irgendwie auch so ein so ein ja,
Äh den den irre ich Honecker Award für Realitäts äh ja und so weiter, ja keine Ahnung. Also alles schöne, schön.
Genau. Da müsste man wahrscheinlich im Podcast-Universum ein paar ähnliche Kategorien aufmachen. Ansonsten äh habe ich's ja nicht so mit Awards.
Ich will einen Award haben, aber also wir haben uns, wir haben äh leider eine Putt in der, in der Logbuch Netzpolitik Redaktion, ob wir einen, ob wir einen Grimma online Award haben wollen oder nicht.
Das ist so ein bisschen so wie äh also das ist so ein bisschen so wie ähm,
Das ist so ein bisschen so wie ein Friedensnobelpreis, ne. Ich meine, du kriegst immer noch relativ,
wenn du ihn bekommst. Andererseits haben ihn halt irgendwie Henry Kissenger äh.
Hatte Obama und so bekommen, also wo du dann halt auch denkst, okay, möchtest du ernsthaft mit denen in einer Reihe stehen? Was nicht heißen soll, dass man nicht mit den Grimma Online-Preisträgern in einer Reihe stehen möchte, nur dass es dann natürlich durchaus Schwankungen in der äh in der Leistung äh gibt.
Die da jeweils ausgezeichnet wurde.
Ja, also ich atme da schwer. Es gibt ja auch in der Podcastszene mal wieder so Bestrebungen, irgendwelche Awards aufzumachen. Da frage ich mich halt immer wieder, was sind die Kriterien? Wer soll die bewerten, ja,
wer stimmt darüber ab? Und am Ende gewinnen immer äh die, wo,
wo die Community am meisten aufgestachelt wird, ja? Das sind dann irgendwelche Projekte, die dann,
Was weiß ich, so ihre treuen Follower haben und die jubeln dann und fühlen sich irgendwie wie die Geilsten und der Rest denkt sich nur, was für ein irrelevanter Quatsch.
So und am Ende ist da nichts geworden. Das hat so ein bisschen was mit diesen Flair-Buttons irgendwie in Restaurants, in amerikanischen Restaurants.
Die Millionen Preisgeld von so einem äh Friedensnobelpreis, die ist schon oder ah nein, es war das war gar nicht der Friendsnobelpreis, ne?
Millionen Preisgeld. Wo siehst du eine Million Preis.
Bei irgendeinem Preis gibt's bestimmt eine Million. Ich glaube beim ähm beim richtigen Nobelpreis.
Online Award. Du träumst.
Christen feuchten Händedruck und.
Ja, bestenfalls. Darfst du wahrscheinlich noch deine deine Reise zur Verleihung selber bezahlen, ja.
Ja, natürlich. Ja, ich weiß nicht. Okay, Grimma online Award, ähm.
Und diese ganze Warerei, das ist alles Quatsch. Es gibt nur einen Award, es gibt irgendwie Treuehörer und äh ordentlich Support und ordentlich Feedback, das ist wie der beste Award, den man haben kann.
Dein Wort in Grimmes Ohr. Okay.
Du machst mich fertig.
Lass uns lieber hier ein bisschen äh Follow abmachen zum letzten Mal. Da haben wir ja äh herausgepickt, was für ein ähm ja,
Zweifelhafter Charakter doch äh Mister Cameron, der englische Ministerpräsident ist. Und naja, jetzt äh,
wo er aber schon mal den ersten Schritt gemacht hat, sind äh dann alle aus der zweiten Reihe hervorgekommen und haben dann einfach dasselbe Lied,
mitgesungen. Ich glaube, Obama war der erste, der sich aus der Reserve getraut hat, der war schon mal ganz dankbar, dass dann so die
Inselvasallen da äh schon mal vorgelegt haben und meint so, ah ja hier, das stimmt ja auch alles mal total. Also worum geht's überhaupt? Es geht um die ähm,
Bewertung der Situation ist ja viel zu viel Verschlüsselung gibt und dass ja der Staat überhaupt nicht mal äh reinhören kann, schon gar nicht in extrem ist, also in in eine Notfall äh Situation, die er am laufenden Meter äh auftritt,
Und ähm das könne ja nicht sein, dass äh auf einmal ist Softwareverschlüsselungsverfahren äh verwendet, wo der Staat keinen Zugang hat. Also was ich ganz schön finde, ist, dass an der Stelle auch so eine
zum Beispiel von Frank Krieger auch ähm.
Finde ich ganz gut zur Anwendung kommt, so wenn man nur mal die technischen Maßnahmen mal richtig festzonen würde und das mit der Krypto mal ernst nehmen würde und so, dann wird es auf einmal ganz schön teuer. So und so eine Nervosität würde sich nicht zeigen, wenn äh
wenn aus den Geheimdiensten nur die Botschaft kommen würde auch alles kein Problem, können wir alles mitlesen, kein kein Thema, sondern jetzt wird's halt wirklich schwierig.
Also mithören können, ja, das ist ja, also wir hatten da letzte Woche schon so ein bisschen drüber gesprochen, wir wollen in dieser Woche ähm nachdem wir dem politischen Teil haben, nochmal,
den technischen, den die technischen Aspekte nochmal ein bisschen mehr vertiefen, aber was ja das Spannende ist ja.
Überleg mal, welche von welchen Regierungen wir gerade hören, dass sie im Notfall mal,
ne, mit Warren und allem, ja?
Mhm. Mit Richterbeschluss.
Richterbeschluss und haste nicht gesehen, irgendwie im Extremfall mal in verschlüsselte Kommunikation reinschauen wollen,
das ist halt irgendwie äh die Regierung der Entschuldigung, das ist die Regierung, die irgendwie hat.
Mhm.
Und die Regierung, die die NSA haben, ja, das sind die beiden,
Offensichtlich dokumentiert extremistischen äh rücksichtslosesten Geheimdienste der Welt, die auf gar keine Scheiß Legislatur, die es bis jetzt schon gibt, in irgendeiner Form jemals Rücksicht genommen hätten, ja? Und das also das ist halt wirklich,
Allein die Idee, dass du dich irgendwie als als äh äh Primeminister
dahin stellst und sagst so also das kann ja nicht sein dass wir da nicht also natürlich mit mit allen möglichen und demokratischer Kontrolle und Richter vorbehalten mal reinschauen können wenn du irgendwie dokumentiert diese Geheimgerichte hast, wie halt den ähm,
äh Fisk ähm FA den Foren Intelligence äh und in den äh in den UK das ICT äh das IPT Investigutori,
Ähm IPT, ja? Ähm,
die alle irgendwie so dir wo riesengroß dransteht so hier,
nichts mit demokratischer Kontrolle, alles nur mit, wir können alles, wir machen, was wir wollen. Ähm wie du dich äh
irgendwie da überhaupt noch vor die Medien stellen kannst und so eine
so eine Forderung aufstellen kannst und ernsthafte dich da noch auf irgendwelche demokratischen Kontrollen berufen kannst, ohne dass irgendwie die gesamte Pressekonferenz ins ins wilde Lachen ausbricht, ist allein schon ein Rätsel.
Das ähm aber okay. Das wollte ich nur nochmal kurz anmerken.
Ähm und du sagtest es schon ähm Obama äh sagte dann ja, ne, da müsste man sich schon Gedanken drüber machen, de Maizire äh äh sagt sie dann,
deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden müssen befugt und in der Lage sein, verschlüsselte Kommunikation zu entschlüsseln und zu umgehen, wenn dies für ihre Arbeits und Schutz der Bevölkerung notwendig ist.
Effektive Ermittlungen zur Strafverfolgung müssen auch im Cyberraum möglich sein. Und dann trat auch noch der EU-Antiterrorkoordinator,
Ähm hervor und sagte, er möchte gerne Internet und Telekommunikation,
Telekommunikationsanbieter zum Einbau von Hintertüren für verschlüsselte Kommunikation zwingen können. Und in diesem Papier, dass er da ähm verbreitet hat zur Vorbereitung der Sitzung der EU-Innenminister,
Ähm sagte er also, dass in Folge der NSA-Affäre viele IT-Anbieter dezentrale Verschlüsselungsverfahren anbieten.
Was das behördliche Abhören zusehens erschwert. Ja, also wenn wir uns anschauen, bei äh WhatsApp war das irgendwie am Anfang brauchtest du da so ungefähr einfach mal gar nichts, um das abhören zu können,
Ähm dann haben sie irgendwann äh ihr SSL halbwegs in den Griff bekommen und äh dann haben sie irgendwann in den Griff bekommen, wie sie die Kies pro, die Weiß herstellen und so. Und das ist nach und nach immer schwieriger geworden.
Und ähm dieser Entwicklung, diese Entwicklung macht den also tatsächlich Schwierigkeiten.
Na ja, immerhin also das war äh nicht unbedingt äh sicher.
Dass das das für die jetzt ernsthaft ein Problem werden würde und.
Jetzt sagen sie eben oder jetzt soll die EU Kommission eben rechtliche Möglichkeiten suchen, nach denen Firmen zur Herausgabe von Schlüsseln gezwungen werden können.
Ähm da werden wir also noch in eigentlich dem günstigsten Fall, dass die Firma,
die diese Schlüssel oder die dieses Verschlüsselungsverfahren anbietet, irgendwie zur Herausgabe der Schlüssel gezwungen wird, denn da hättest du dann immer noch.
Hoffentlich im Idealfall einen Schlüssel, den sie rausgeben müssen.
Hinterlegt ist, beziehungsweise, dass erzwingen der Herausgabe letzten Endes eine freiwillige Zugriff, ein freiwilliger Zugriff durch die Geheimdienste ist, den, auf den die Firma dann gar keinen Eingriff mehr äh Einfluss mehr hat. Genau.
Genau, aber gehen wir mal davon aus, also um ich denke, wir haben äh den die politischen Implikationen einer solchen Forderung schon in der letzten Sendung.
Ganz gut äh dargestellt. Ähm aber ähm
Vielleicht sollte man auf den auf den technischen Teil nochmal eingehen, wie könnte man
das denn äh realisieren? Man könnte also sagen, okay, ähm bei diesem ganzen Close Force Anbietern, die zwingen wir quasi zum Einbau einer Backboard. Das heißt, irgendwie äh WhatsApp kann zwar von uns aus schön ähm,
Texte zu Ende Verschlüsselungen machen. Die müssen aber in dem Moment, wo die, wo das äh Programm irgendwie einen Secret Key ähm erstellt, diesen äh auch nochmal mit dem,
Mit dem, der
Der NSA verschlüsselt, äh zu sich selber schicken, sodass WhatsApp und niemand anders nach wie vor Zugriff drauf nach wie vor keinen Zugriff drauf haben. Ähm
aber die NSA eben sich dieses Schlüssel bemächtigen könnte und das äh dass die Kommunikation wieder entschlüsseln könnte. Sowas wären zum Beispiel Möglichkeiten,
Ein anderer Aspekt, den ich aber äh finde, dass wir es versäumt haben, dass im letzten äh Mal ähm auch nochmal zu betonen ist, dass,
Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung, zumindest in Deutschland, der ähm,
die Begründung dafür ist, dass es die, dass es Staatstrojaner geben soll. Weil man nämlich sagt, ähm.
Oder die Begründung für dafür ist, wie man.
Eine juristische Basis dafür geschaffen hat, dass man Staatstrojaner bauen könnte,
ja? Nämlich die Gesetzgebung der Quellen-Telekommunikationsüberwachung. Wo man sich also überlegt hat, okay, wenn wir äh hingehen und richterlich anordnen, äh der Tim ist Terrorist. Wir müssen seine Kommunikation überwachen,
dann können wir damit zum, zu seinem E-Mail Provider gehen, ähm dann können wir damit äh zu seinem Telefonanbieter gehen, dann können wir damit im Zweifelsfall sogar zu seinem.
Serveranbieter gehen und eine TKÜ auf auf dem Metaebene Server machen. Das heißt, da wird dann ein ähm die der Traffic dieses Servers aufgezeichnet. Das das geht alles. Aber was machen wir jetzt, wenn der Tim,
über äh PGP verschlüsselt. Und äh darüber mit dem Linus sich verabredet, wann die ihre äh Klangdestinen zum zum Piratensender Logbuch Netzpolitik machen.
So und dann hätten wir, dann hätten wir die einzige sinnvolle Möglichkeit, diese Kommunikation abzufangen, wenn wir das an der Quelle tun, nämlich während der Tim
die E-Mail schreibt
Quellen, Telekommunikationsüberwachung, bevor also die E-Mail verschlüsselt und übertragen wird. Und dann wurde gesagt, okay, wenn wir an die Quelle wollen, dann müssen wir den Computer von Tim infizieren.
Und uns eine Möglichkeit schaffen, ihn beim Schreiben der E-Mail quasi abzuhören, bevor diese E-Mail abgesendet wird. Also wir müssen Computer trojanisieren und ähm,
Das wäre eine weitere technische Möglichkeit.
Um äh Verschlussende zu Endeverschlüsselungsverfahren zu umgehen.
Nicht auf äh Systemen, die sich die entsprechend abgesichert sind. Ich meine, das ist so eine ja.
Na ja, also ich sage ja, erstmal nur die theoretische Möglichkeit, ja. So und jetzt könntest du natürlich sagen, okay,
Ähm und da daraus ergibt sich dann dieser äh in der Folge eben diese Abwägung aus dem Grundrecht auf äh
Integrität unserer Informationsverarbeitenden Systeme, dass eben minimal ähm minimalinvasiv verletzt werden soll im Rahmen einer äh äh Quellentelekommunikationsüberwachung. Und was eben bei den Trojanern,
Bei der Trojanisierung von Rechnern eben nicht der Fall ist. Ja, das hat dann äh Implikationen für die forensische äh Verwertbarkeit von Informationen.
Wenn man sagt, okay, dieser Computer ist trojanisiert und der Trojaner, der da drauf ist, hat äh die Möglichkeit, äh Dateien auf dieses Datesystem zu schreiben, dann kannst du nicht mehr davon ausgehen, dass irgendetwas, was du an diesem Computer
vorfindest, überhaupt noch ähm.
Von dem äh von dem von der von dem Ziel der Überwachung stammt, ja, da gibt's also noch eine eine ganze Reihe weiterer Implikationen, die dann da eine Rolle spielen. Aber diesen Teil haben wir also.
Versäumt auch nochmal darzustellen, dass sich darin eben auch eine technische Möglichkeit äh.
Darstellt, dieses In Extremes äh zu realisieren. Und ähm.
Eine andere Möglichkeit, die ich eben grade schon kurz erwähnt habe, wären also so Krypto-Bectors, dass du sagst, okay, jeder einzelne Nachricht wird.
Ähm auch noch einmal.
Mit dem Schlüssel der NSA verschlüsselt. Ja, also Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselungsverfahren.
Funktionieren. Ähm grob so, dass die dass jede jede Nachricht ähm mit einem ähm,
symmetrischen Schlüssel verschlüsselt wird und dieser Schlüssel wiederum asymmetrisch verschlüsselt vorne dransteht, sodass ich in der Lage bin, auch eine PGP-Nachricht an mehrere Empfänger zu schicken,
Die PGP-Nachricht ist dann so aufgebaut, dass äh vorne drin steht, ähm,
vorne für für mehrere Empfänger verschlüsselt, der Schlüssel zu dieser Nachricht drinsteht.
Ja? Und dann kannst du sehen, ah, diese Nachricht ist verschlüsselt an. Äh Linus, Tim äh und den Gast der nächsten Sendung,
Und das, was aber eigentlich dann verschlüsselt ist, ist nur der Schlüssel zu dem Rest der Nachricht. Hm? Und es wäre jetzt also kein Problem, die Protokolle so umzubauen, dass halt immer automatisch auch noch der NSA-Schlüssel mit dabei ist.
Und dadurch würdest du nicht unbedingt ähm,
wirklich die Kryptographie schwächen, das heißt, das Risiko, dass jemand anders dich abhört, ähm wird.
Zumindest nicht für den Fall, dass jemand anders diese Nachrichten mitschneidet größer, weil dieser jemand anders immer noch den Schlüssel der NSA bräuchte.
Also technisch gesehen ähm wird dadurch nicht unbedingt.
Je nachdem wie man's implementiert, implementiert wird, technisch gesehen, dadurch nicht unbedingt deine deine tatsächliche Sicherheit geschwächt
Das finde ich halt auch nochmal wichtig zu sagen, weil wir äh letztes Mal uns noch so mehr darauf konzentriert haben, dass es um ein Verbot ähm wirksamer Verschlüsselung gäbe. Aber es gehe, es gäbe eben auch noch Möglichkeiten, ähm.
Das zu realisieren, ohne dass ähm dass die Sicherheit des,
Individuums gegen andere, abhörende Instanzen äh unbedingt besonders,
sinken würde. Das wollte ich nochmal ähm betonen.
Politisch ausgedrückt.
Ich meine, man muss ja zumindest auch mal die technischen Möglichkeiten ähm sinnvoll erläutern. Davon ähm unabhängig steht natürlich, dass also von dieser technischen Erwägung unabhängig, ähm steht natürlich, dass,
der der die politische Implikation, dass das einfach absolut ähm inakzeptabel ist. Jegliches Briefgeheimnis,
vollständig aufzuweichen.
Und jegliches Kommunikationsgeheimnis. Und das ist mir sicher bin, dass äh wir hoffentlich noch in in allen unseren Verfassungen irgendetwas versteckt haben, was derartige Legislatur auch ähm verhindern würde.
Ja, also mir ist das ein Rätsel, wie sie das ähm durchsetzen wollen. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich kann mir das nicht anders vorstellen, als dass sie wirklich komplett in so ein Russland und China-Modus gehen.
Was ich ja irgendwie noch nicht so richtig glauben will, dass wir so auf so einem Pfad sind.
Also oder zumindest, dass wir so ein Pfad wirklich erfolgreich einschlagen äh könnten,
In unserer Gesellschaft, weil einfach der Widerstand durch Wirtschaft und letzten Endes auch äh NGOs und andere Gruppen da einfach äh zu groß ist, um zu weit kommen zu lassen. Beziehungsweise,
und irgendwie habe ich noch so das Gefühl, es gibt noch so einen Rest,
allgemein Verständnis, dass dass das vielleicht nicht der richtige Weg ist. Jetzt gleich so abzugehen wie China.
Ja, natürlich. Also, wie gesagt, die die politischen,
Die politischen Implikationen sind äh unerhört und äh gefährlich und ähm es ist auch klar, dass man diesen ähm.
Personenkreisen, die diesen Vorschlag machen, auch in keiner Form trauen kann. Und deswegen ist das ähm.
Ist es halt also ein ein absolut nicht hinnehmbarer Vorstoß, der mit aller äh Kraft zu bekämpfen ist. Mir ging's nur darum, auch von der technischen Seite zumindest mir nicht den Vorwurf machen können, lassen zu müssen.
Dass ich da nicht darauf hingewiesen habe, dass es sozusagen minimalinvasive Möglichkeiten gibt, die mit sehr großer Sicherheit nur den äh Geheimdiensten, die,
dich nicht darüber informieren, dass sie deine Kommunikation abhören und das auch ohne jeglichen ähm,
demokratische Basis tun, den Zugriff zu ermöglichen, ohne ähm anderen Geheimdiensten, denen diese Geheimdienste wiederum nicht trauen äh den Zugriff zu ermöglichen.
Was ich auch schon mal verständlicher ausgerückt, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall äh das wäre alles richtig schlecht. Äh allein schon deshalb, weil niemand mehr richtig drüber nachdenken könnte, was jetzt wirklich sichere Verfahren wären, weil man immer alles äh unter dem
Aspektdesign müsste das jetzt da so eine Vektor möglich ist in irgendeiner Form. Also ist alles albern. Wir sind dagegen und ähm.
Ist hochgefährlich und ähm.
Geht alles gar nicht.
Um das zu untermauern, kommen wir zum nächsten Thema. Denn äh das GCAQ.
Hat Journalisten abgehört. Und zwar E-Mails von BBC Reuters, dem Guardian, der New York Times, Le Mont, The Sun, NBC und der Washington Post, äh wurden
von dem abgefangen, gespeichert und auch ähm äh innerhalb des Intranetz geteilt,
zur Analyse. Als Teil eines kleinen einer ähm Signals Intelligence Übung, einer Testübung, ja? Da haben sie nämlich einfach mal ähm zehn Minuten lang,
Im November zweitausendachtzehn ähm an ihren an ihren an ihren Fiber Tabs, also an ihren äh Glasfaserkabel, Abhöranlagen, äh eben siebzig äh tausend E-Mails,
gesammelt.
Und äh diese auf diesen einfach mal so ein bisschen geübt. Ja, also verschiedene Algorithmen äh äh ausprobiert, wo sie einfach mal schauen wollten, wie man äh wie man denn mit diesen Daten umgehen kann, wie man Sachen aussortieren kann.
Also wohlgemerkt jetzt keine äh explizite Aktion, die angestoßen wurde, dass überhaupt erstmal was abgefangen wird, sondern aus dem, was ohnehin abgefangen wurde, wurde dann eben einfach mal gezielt extrahiert.
Und äh dann haben sie da die Nase reingehalten zehn Minuten
an einem Tag so mal eben so mal geguckt na wo sind sie denn hier die Mails und da sieht man auch sehr schön wie
zielgerichtet man da eben vorgehen kann. So, ja, wir wollen mal hier die E-Mail-Verkehr von diesen Institutionen haben, da machen wir mal kurz diesen Schalter an, so,
und dann fertig, zehn Minuten später, haben alle was zum Spielen, sehr hübsch.
So und dann, das ist ähm ja denke ich jetzt auch nix Neues. Also ich meine, welchen Teil von,
die hören alles ab, ähm haben wir nicht verstanden, ja, also.
Interessant war das, dass diese Meldung flankiert wurde von,
Journalisten als ein Risiko zwischen Terroristen und Hackern ein.
Und das war ähm da müsste man vielleicht, da wurde auch, glaube ich, nicht so nicht so gut äh drüber berichtet, nicht so ausführlich. Da wurde also gesagt, okay.
Ähm und zwar hat das äh GCHQ da ein Information Security Risk Assessment gemacht, ja? Wo man also hingeht und sagt, okay.
Welche Angreifer oder Feindesgruppen haben wir? Was wollen die?
Was können die und welchen Schaden kann das für uns bedeuten, ja? Ähm macht ähm jedes Unternehmen auch, ähm wenn sie irgendwie eine halbwegs vernünftige Sicherheitsabteilung haben, weil du nämlich,
quasi du hast ja letztendlich ein äh ein Budget an Möglichkeiten, wie du,
in Schutz, IT-Sicherheitsschutz investieren kannst. Ähm du hast eine relativ große Infrastruktur, auf der sich äh auf die sich verschiedene,
ähm Daten verteilen ähm und dann überlegst du quasi, was gibt es für Angreifergruppen und welche Motivationen haben die? Und dementsprechend schaust du dann,
mit dieser Motivation, was von dem, was wir hier haben, würden die angreifen,
und wie äh investiere ich dementsprechend in Schutz. Ja?
Und ähm was ist also eigentlich eine eine relativ normale Informationssicherheits äh Übung.
Und das hat das äh GCHQ an der Stelle auch gemacht und die Variablen, die sie sich da so äh gewählt haben, waren ähm ähm.
Und Priority. Ich hätt's ein bisschen anders gemacht, aber sie haben also gesagt, okay ähm äh ein ein Journalist.
Hat ein also einen Fähigkeitswert von äh zwei auf einer Skala von äh null oder eins bis fünf äh und eine äh Priorität von drei.
Und das Ergebnis ist, dass das Gesamtrisiko, was von dieser Personengruppe für unsere äh Informationssicherheit ausgeht, eher niedrig ist. Ein äh Terrorist hat höhere Fähigkeiten.
Aber eine niedrigere äh Priorität und das resultiert aus einer äh moderaten äh Bedrohung für unser Informationssicher.
Meinen sie denn mit Priorität.
Äh wie gesagt, ich hätte da andere Variablen gewählt. Üblicherweise machst du sowas wie ähm Fähigkeit und ähm Motivation.
Ja, also ähm Priority äh also da werden sie intern, wird sich da eine äh eine relativ klare Herleitung dieser Matrix äh in einem Report befinden und es ist auch also es diese Matrix wurde,
oder habe ich nicht in ihrer Gänze gefunden, sondern es wurde in diesen Artikeln nur daraus zitiert, aber du sagst quasi so, ähm.
Und vor allem steht eigentlich, würde da noch dahinter stehen, was wollen die eigentlich? Ja, also worauf worauf zielen die ab? Also so als Beispiel äh würdest du jetzt als Unternehmen dann zum so sagen, okay,
ähm nehmen wir mal äh Nonne, ja. Was ist deren Motivation? Die wollen in der Regel,
Infrastruktur lahmlegen durch die Nylove Serviceangriffe. Ähm das heißt äh.
Und dadurch ist unser Risi das Risiko, was dem Unternehmen entsteht, ist irgendwie halt schlechte Presse oder so.
Und ähm man muss also gegen die in der Regel nur seine,
seine Redundanz und irgendwie hochhalten. Ja, aber man hat jetzt nicht das Risiko, dass die äh eine Datenbank aufmachen.
Wäre jetzt so die Einschätzung, ne? Andererseits, dann gibt's ja noch so und so. Also so versuchst du irgendwie halt zu überlegen, ähm,
Wer sind deine Gegner und wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass die
wirkliche Angriffe auf deine Infrastruktur fahren und wie erkennst du diese Angriffe oder wie unterbindest du diese Angriffe am besten? Das ist das, was sie da äh gemacht zu haben scheint. Und natürlich sind weder äh Journalisten noch,
Terroristen wirklich etwas, worüber die sich bei der Planung ihrer IT,
Security Gedanken machen müssen. Bei Hackern sieht's natürlich schon anders aus. Also da wird sich wahrscheinlich drin befinden irgendwie in der gleichen Tabelle wird wahrscheinlich sowas stehen wie chinesischer Hacker, hohe Cape, hohe Priority, großes Risiko.
Also irgendwie sowas. Und daraus dann diese Tabelle machst du einmal grundsätzlich und dann multiplizierst du das quasi auch mit dem äh was deine einzelnen Infrastrukturkomponenten oder Architekturen für diese Person bieten. Ja?
Bei meinem chinesischen Hacker ist das halt überall ein Risiko, da gibt's kaum was, was du vor dem äh nicht irgendwie in in Schutz bringen musst.
Na ja, interessant ist natürlich die die Headline, die daraus natürlich auch gemacht wurde, so auf äh investigative Journalisten stehen da in einem Whisky Assessment mit Terroristen und Hackern.
Ja. Ja, alle dann letzten Endes, ne, also.
Ja aber also wie gesagt, solche Analysen gehen in der Regel noch sehr viel weiter. Da kommt nicht nur eine Matrix bei raus, sondern auf
auf der auf der Basis dieser Matrix werden dann noch sehr viel ähm.
Sehr viel weitere äh Überlegungen angestellt und diese Matrix ändert sich ja auch, je nachdem äh worum es geht. Also wenn du jetzt von
Social Engineering-Angriffen redest und nicht von irgendwie Angriffen auf deine auf deine Datenbank, dann kommen natürlich diese investigativen äh Journalisten, denen kommt dann halt eine sehr viel größere Rolle zu.
Das wollte ich eigentlich nur mal so ein bisschen erklären, dass das jetzt,
nicht unbedingt heißt, dass äh der äh Journalisten auf eine Ebene mit mit Hackern und ähm Terroristen stellt,
Aber es zeigt, dass der, dass das äh GCHQ und jeder andere Geheimdienst.
Offensichtlich ähm investigative Journalisten als,
potentielle Bedrohung für ihre Interessen und Aktivitäten sieht. Das wiederum ist aber jetzt auch keine Überraschung nach dem äh nach dem Geschehnissen der letzten Jahre.
Ja, insbesondere beim Guardian et cetera.
Genau, das also jetzt Geheimdienste, investigative Journalisten nicht mehr so geil finden, ähm ist, ist.
Und umgekehrt.
Das haben sie sich äh mühsam mühsam erarbeitet, die investigativen Journalisten und eine der Früchte, die sie dafür ernten, ist natürlich, dass sie jetzt auch als auf auf solchen Risiko äh Assessment Matrizen auftauchen.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch dazu.
Ja
Ja, Überbringer, schlechter Nachrichten müssen auch bestraft werden. Das ist natürlich äh nicht nur in äh England von großer Wichtigkeit, nein, auch in,
Sachsen scheint das eine hohe Priorität zu haben. Wir erinnern uns, es äh gab ja in den letzten Wochen und auch immer noch diese merkwürdigen äh.
Diese komischen Idas, genau, gerade einen äh schönen Artikel gelesen mit ähm.
Ganzen Leute, die auf Montagsdemos rumlaufen, als,
Warenwichtel bezeichnet das, fand ich ja großartig, ein ganz toller Artikel. Auch gleich nochmal an die Links. Und äh äh Warnwichtel und Abkürzungsnazis, genau. Das war die.
Hast du.
Ihre Formulierungen.
Kleiner kleiner Spaß am Rande. Hast du das äh mitbekommen, dass sie jetzt völlig überraschend festgestellt haben, dass dieser Lutz Bachmann Nazi ist? Wirklich? Ja, unglaublich, oder? Hättest du das dir vorstellen können.
Wirklich? Ja. Jetzt schon. Na ja, na, jetzt hat er ja sich mit mit Hitler-Bärtchen irgendwie auf Facebook gesonnt und äh dann ist ja klar, ne?
Und er hat äh hat halt auch mehrere irgendwie in den vergangenen Jahren äh relativ viele eindeutig äh rassistische Tweets und Facebook-Nachrichten irgendwie verbreitet. Ähm denen dann irgendwie von äh.
Timeline weit genug zurückgescrollt oder was?
Genau, dann sind meine Timeline weit genug zurückgescrollt und interessanterweise, was ich ganz spannend fand, also das sind dann so Tweets von zweitausenddreizehn, zweitausendvierzehn oder so, wo dann halt, ja, äh,
Schimpfworte für für Menschen anderer Hautfarben äh äh,
verwendet werden, bestimmte relativ einfache Vorurteile über Berufstätigkeit und Einkommens äh Möglichkeiten äh von Personengruppen verbreitet werden und zwar so
plumpe äh rassistische Parolen halt. Und ähm völlig überraschend, ja, dass jemand, der ähm,
Demonstrationen äh für die gegen die Islamisierung des Abendlandes in ein in einem Land wie Sachsen an abhält, wo irgendwie weit und breit alle ähm.
Menschen, die es können, schon längst geflohen sind vor den vor den äh vor den Einwohnern, vor den Ureinwohnern. Ähm.
Ureinwanderern.
Von den Urein Wanderern.
Auf jeden Fall ähm völlig überraschend äh stellte sich jetzt raus, dass dass der Typ Ausländerfeindlich ist und ähm dann gab's interessanterweise ähm.
Die Frage, ob denn diese Tweets und Facebook-Einträge eventuell gefälscht sind? Oder sein könnten,
Ja, also hat vielleicht jemand den Account gehackt und äh dann ja das, also die theoretische Möglichkeit besteht und das wäre dann also so, dass jemand,
zweitausendzwölf, zweitausenddreizehn in die Glaskugel geschaut hat,
festgestellt hat, in ein paar Jahren wird dieser Mann eine zentrale Rolle spielen. Wir hacken am besten jetzt schon mal dessen Twitter-Account und verbreiten Naziparolen, um den dann in zweieinhalb Jahren anhand dieser Parolen diskreditieren zu können.
Das wäre die eine Möglichkeit, so die Wahrscheinlichkeit kann man sich ausrechnen, denn natürlich haben diese
Tweets und Facebook Einträge eben TimeStamps, die eben weit in der in die Vergangenheit zurückreichen. Die andere Möglichkeit ist, dass jemand tatsächlich Facebook und Twitter so tief gehackt hat, dass er in deren Datenbank Veränderungen vornehmen kann, also,
Änderungen an der äh an deren äh Datensatz vornehmen kann, die über die Rechte eines einzelnen Nutzers hinausgehen, denn natürlich bist du nicht in der Lage, bei Twitter oder bei Facebook in als normalen Nutzer Einträge in der Vergangenheit zu zu äh zu posten, ja?
Ja, ich meine, das ist doch vollkommen unvorstellbar, weil äh wenn wenn so was
wäre, dann müsste es ja auch große geheim äh Operierende Organisationen geben, die einen unglaublichen Etat zur Verfügung haben mit unglaublich viel Computer und Netzwerktechnologie äh von hinten äh gegen alle Firmen äh vorzugehen.
Hm ja.
Ja, aber die müssten dann halt noch eine Motivation haben, also drum, was ist das denn für ein Unsinn? Dann müssten die ja noch eine Motivation haben, äh irgendwie diese Fähigkeit,
dafür dranzugeben, dass sie irgendwie irgend so ein dahergelaufenen Nazi ähm.
Nazi-Tweets in, also das ist ja totaler Quatsch, ne? Das ist also ich würde sagen, es ist ähm.
Ein Krimineller, der irgendwie ins Ausland geflüchtet ist, um dort Schutz vor den deutschen Zugriff zu nehmen, muss man dazu sagen. Der Herr Bachmann.
Wo ist wohin ist er geflüchtet?
Na, da ist doch irgendwie äh wegen Körperverletzung und anderen äh äh Delikten äh hatte er dann auch mal das Land verlassen und ist dann irgendwie nach Südafrika geflohen und ist da dann aber leider ausgewiesen worden. Also wie,
Bock auf Ausländer hatten, keine Ahnung, aber der Typ geht gar nicht, wie auch immer. Wir wollen ja auch gar nicht über Herrn Bachmann reden.
Kurz feststellen, weil es tatsächlich ernsthafte Anfragen gab und zwar nicht zu knapp in dieser Richtung. So, der Typ ist, äh, es sollte keinen überraschen, dass dieser Typ ein Nazi ist. Es sollte.
Keiner in Frage stellen, dass dieser Typ ein Krimineller ist, ähm mehrfach verurteilt und die Idee, dass ähm dass diese Äußerungen irgendwie von Hackern oder ähm äh Kommunikationsgesten,
ähm eingebaut wurden, ist also.
Heißt das.
Ähm ähm ist äh sehr, sehr abwegig.
Sehr abwegig, dass es große Geheimorganisationen gibt, die mit großer technischen Fähigkeit.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum du das jetzt anbringst. Das ist halt totaler Unsinn und Kontraproduktiv in dem Bereich. Willst du jetzt irgendwie nahelegen, dass äh dass die NSA irgendwie einen Nazi als Nazi diskreditieren möchte?
Ich will überhaupt nix nahelegen. Ich sage nur, es ist ja voll, also ist vollkommen unvorstellbar.
Okay, also ähm kommen wir zurück zum Thema.
Genau, kommen wir kurz zurück zum Thema. Das Thema ist nämlich, dass äh im Rahmen dieser ganzen äh Eskalationen in äh Dresden äh ist ja einen Mord gab. Ähm an.
Ja, leider nicht in Dresden, um dich da direkt mal zu korrigieren.
Sondern? Entschuldigung in Leipzig, ja.
In Leipzig ist ein ähm ein äh Geflüchteter namens oder ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht. Ähm aufgefunden, tot aufgefunden worden letzte Woche.
In Dresden ist das gewesen, mein Freund.
Die Demo war dann in Leipzig.
Weiß ja nicht ganz genau, was dein, ja, die Demo war in Leipzig, äh auf die wir jetzt zu sprechen kommen wollen, aber der äh die Ermordung war in Dresden.
Und äh deswegen ist das halt auch explizit in diesen äh Schatten dieser ganzen Pegida-Geschichte zu sehen, weil natürlich.
Äh Migrantenflüchtlinge sich natürlich jetzt einfach unter anderem und ähm enorm Bedrohungen schon gesehen haben und jetzt noch mehr,
Ist halt einfach erstochen worden. Das hat die Polizei aber nicht sofort zur Kenntnis genommen, sondern äh als sie ihn gefunden hat, oder an mehreren Stellen äh blutete, waren sie der Meinung, der müsste irgendwo aus dem Haus gefallen sein und,
kein Fremdverschulden ähm zu erkennen gewesen und deswegen wurde auch der Tatort nicht entsprechend äh untersucht und äh als sie dann nach einem Tag
ihren Fehler bemerkt haben, war also der Tatort auch entsprechend ungesichert schon von vielen Leuten belatscht worden et cetera, sprich eine ordentliche Spuren
Aufnahme, wie das eigentlich der Standard sein sollte in solchen Fällen, ist nicht erfolgt,
Ja und das hat natürlich nochmal eine ganze Menge Gegendemonstrationen nach sich gezogen und äh wie man sich denken kann, äh ist das halt so aus ähm linken Kreisen vor allem,
Betrieben worden. Ja.
Ne, ich würde also du stellst das so dar, das hat natürlich Demonstrationen nach sich gezogen. Ich meine, ey, da ist ein Mensch, der sehr offensichtlich,
unter Fremdeinwirkung gestorben ist, ja? Und die Polizei äh gibt erstmal bekannt, dass da kein Fremdverschulden zu erkennen sei und macht sich noch nicht mal die Mühe, das irgendwie zu untersuchen, ja,
Wenn das jetzt ähm,
Also es ist sowas von offenkundig, dass dieser Todesfall anders untersucht worden wäre und mit einer anderen Priorität und mit einem anderen Brimborium von der Polizei untersucht worden wäre, wenn es sich dabei nicht um einen,
um ein äh um eine geflüchtete Person anderer Hautfarbe gehandelt hätte. Das ist doch ein Skandal in sich.
Ja ja und,
hier überhaupt gar keine Skandale absprechen. Ich sage ja nur, es hat einfach entsprechende äh äh entsprechende Aufregungen gegeben und das scheint dann aber auch da so das Kern äh Problem zu sein. Ich bin jetzt gerade etwas am Straucheln durch deine,
Dresden äh da in Dresden Leipzig Spagat, weil es gab natürlich definitiv auch äh entsprechende Gegendemonstrationen in Dresden, aber hier bezieht sich das jetzt auf eine entsprechende Demonstration, die dann in Leipzig.
Genau, ja, das also äh ich glaube.
So ein bisschen verwirrend.
Glaube ich äh noch nie so lange gebraucht, um zum Thema zu kommen. Wir haben erst den den Abstecher über Twitter und Facebook-Hacks gemacht, dann darüber über die NSA-Weltverschwörung äh zu diskreditierung
von Lutz Bachmann, dann äh über den äh Mord an Kalette in Dresden. Ähm zu dem es dann,
in Anbetracht der legida Proteste
eine Spontandemonstration gab von zwischen dreihundert und sechshundert Personen in Leipzig, die gegen Rassismus demonstriert haben und dabei auch mit Polizeikräften,
und umstehenden Schaufensterscheiben aneinander geraten sind.
Das Ganze resultierte dann darin, äh dass rund einhundertfünfzig Teilnehmer, äh dieser Spontan-Demonstration von der Polizei eingekesselt wurden.
Ja? Also, ich hoffe, wir haben das jetzt nochmal, wir haben's nochmal geschafft, das irgendwie an einen Punkt zu bringen, wo wir uns über den Hergang der Ereignisse einig sind. Und jetzt wurde berichtet, dass die Polizei von diesen eingekesselten Personen.
Alle Handys beschlagnahmt hat,
um die darauf gespeicherten Daten auszuwerten.
Auf Basis welcher rechtlichen Grundlage das erfolgt.
Das ist ja in äh jetzt will ich mir inzwischen von gar nichts mehr sicher, aber Leipzig ist ja in Sachsen. Und in Sachsen spielen ja für die Polizei ähm,
Rechtliche Grundlagen historisch eher untergeordnete Rolle, ja? Das äh ich denke, das ist äh das ist eine Feststellung, die man durchaus so äh machen kann.
Ja, okay.
Ja? Und ähm in einer Pressemitteilung der Polizei, die dann einige Zeit später kam, wurde nicht die genaue Zahl der äh beschlagnahmten Handys äh genannt.
Aber es wurde gesagt, ja, das machen wir jetzt, um Daten auszuwerten, weil uns interessieren vor allem äh Bilder und Videos äh auf diesen Handys.
Die eventuell,
Ähm uns dabei helfen können, äh Störer äh oder Rädelsführer oder äh Kriminelle in diesen Kreisen zu identifizieren. Gleichzeitig haben sie aber natürlich durch die Beschlagnahme dieser Telefone,
Möglichkeit und diese Möglichkeit werden sie garantiert ergreifen. Äh jegliche vorangegangene äh Kommunikation äh in Form von.
SMS in Form von Call locks in Form von einfach den im Telefonbuch gespeicherten Kontakten.
Zu rekonstruieren. Oder anhand der Telefone, die sie da eingesammelt haben, ähm den Telefon.
Besitzer zuzuordnen oder diese Telefone
in äh Zusammenhang mit Daten zu bringen, die sie eventuell bei anderen Gelegenheiten schon gesammelt haben, mit der in Dresden ja sehr beliebten Methode der Funkzellenabfrage,
Ähm das ist also ein ein,
ein ein unerhörter ein unerhörter Eingriff, ja? Also wir haben ja schon von
mehrmals jetzt von dem Recht auf äh Integrität unserer Informationsverarbeitenden gesprochen und äh eine eine Massenbeschlagnahme von derart persönlichen Informationsverarbeitenden ähm
und zur täglichen Kommunikation, genutzten Systeme, ist ähm also ein absoluter,
Absoluter Skandal.
Ja. Das ist ein Skandal. Ich freue mich allerdings auch immer wieder, warum so unklug vorgegangen wird,
Also ich meine, in so einer Situation ist die Polizei auch so einfach zu machen, da äh entsprechende Zugriffe vorzunehmen. Ich meine, vielleicht wäre das gar nicht zu verhindern gewesen, aber in dem Moment, wo es halt immer wieder mit äh Entglasungen von äh unbeteiligten Geschäften äh zu tun hat, dann läuft das irgendwie immer sehr schnell.
Du hast da ja ein bisschen mehr einen Blick in die Dynamik solcher Demonstrationen. Wie siehst du das?
Also ähm es ist grundsätzlich in Anbetracht der äh,
Allgemeinlage schon nicht besonders zu empfehlen, ein äh Mobiltelefon bei einer Demonstration mit sich zu führen. Ähm,
Beziehungsweise, wenn, dann nicht das regulär benutzte. Ähm das ist schlimm, das so sagen zu müssen, aber äh wie gesagt, bei ähm.
Den äh spätestens seit den Protesten in Dresden anlässlich der dieses Heldengedenkens oder was da immer äh durchgeführt wird. Ähm.
Kann man eben sehen, dass du als äh dass du als normaler Teilnehmer einer Demonstration eben zum Opfer äh unsere Zielpersonen solcher Funkzellen abfragen werden kannst. Ähm dass du eventuell mit deinem Mobiltelefon,
vielleicht noch ein Foto gemacht hast, was,
nachher zur Identifikation ähm einer einer dritten Person, die deren Relevanz, die er gar nicht bekannt ist, äh genutzt werden kann, sollte die dieses Handy abgenommen werden. Ähm,
Kommt dann noch dazu. Also es ist, du musst nicht ein,
äh du musst nicht mit dem Ziel oder der Absicht oder der der Wahrscheinlichkeit zu einer Demonstration gehen, äh dass du dort eventuell äh gegen Gesetze verstößt.
Gesetze verstößt.
Damit es eine dumme Idee ist, dein Handy mitzunehmen. Also das ist leider inzwischen grundsätzlich ist davon abzuraten. Das ist schlimm, das so sagen zu müssen.
Ähm aber,
wir sehen äh was davon kommt, zumindest wenn du dich in Sachsen aufhältst, ne? Also Funkzellenabfrage braucht man jetzt gar nicht mehr nachzufragen. Selbstverständlich haben sie eine solche gemacht in dieser Situation.
Ja, Moment, das Ding ist auf jeden Fall Hardcore und ist auf jeden Fall auch mal wieder so ein Bereich, wo ähm ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das nennen soll.
Politischer Aspekt ist das jetzt nur so am Rande, aber es zeigt einfach auch mal wieder, wie,
Einerseits wie wertvoll diese Geräte sind quasi und wie wie also wie groß die Begehrlichkeiten äh sind, ne? Warum lange mit den Leuten reden, wenn man auch ihre Smartphones einfach äh kassieren kann, einfach mal selber alles durchlesen kann?
Was im Prinzip ja auch einfach durch die Privatsphäre an der Stelle schon geschützt sein sollte, aber offensichtlich nicht ist, zumindest nicht in Leipzig
Ja und wir müssen uns wahrscheinlich auch mehr Gedanken darüber machen, wie frei man in solchen Kritischen Situationen mit solchen Gräten durch die Gegend laufen sollte.
Ja, also überlegt euch, bei welcher Gelegenheit ihr die Geräte mitnehmt und bei welcher Gelegenheit nicht.
Der Trend geht zum Zweithandy.
Der Trend geht zum Zweithandy und äh vielleicht an der Stelle auch mal zu empfehlen ähm.
Sich mit, zumindest basalen Schutzmechanismus auseinanderzusetzen. Also der größere Teil der Smartphones da draußen ist noch nicht mal durch einen Code gesichert.
Und da gab's äh mal einen äh Vortrag bei der äh Republika von meinem Kollegen Ben und mir. Ich habe da,
sehr untergeordnete Rolle äh gespielt, denen wir auch mal in die Shownotes äh linken, wo wir einfach mal so ein bisschen ähm Smartphone
Sicherheit, Basics vermittelt haben, ja, wo es jetzt nicht da unbedingt heißt, dein, dein Smartphone gegen äh die NSA zu schützen, sondern einfach mal gegen denjenigen, der äh dir das unter Anderung von Gewalt wegnimmt.
Wie zum Beispiel ein Dieb oder ein Polizist.
Wir verlinken das. Genau.
So, das waren ja bisher unsere Kurzthemen. Jetzt kommen wir zu den Kurzmeldungen. Mal schauen, wie ausführlich die so werden.
Es gab mal wieder eine neue Ausgabe im Podcast Geheimdienst Untersuchungsausschuss. Diesmal war äh zu Gast,
Stargast, nämlich der ehemalige Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte Peter Schar, immer um äh Wortgewalt nicht verlegen und vor allem auch,
medial deutlich wahrnehmbar als seine Nachfolgerin.
Der sich nicht äußert.
Zu der sich nicht äußert, aha, okay, aber von der habe ich sozusagen, seitdem sie im Amt ist, noch überhaupt nichts so richtig zur Kenntnis genommen, außer, dass ab und zu mal was erzählt wird, dass sie, ja,
sichtbar sei. Wie auch immer, warum war er da?
Na er hat immer so ein bisschen erzählt, also äh er erzählte, dass er nach den Snowden Enthüllung die Aufsichtsbehörden äh der deutschen Nachrichtendienste angeschrieben hat
einige davon hätten aber gar nicht geantwortet, zum Beispiel das Innenministerium haben ihm hat ihm nicht geantwortet.
Also sein Dienstherr.
Genau, dann hat er das formal beanstaltet und eine äh Klage erwogen, diese aber dann letztendlich doch nicht eingereicht. Ähm.
Er hätte dann ähm,
nach weiteren Enthüllungen ein paar Prüfungen durch seine Behörde veranlasst zum Beispiel äh in Berlin sich mit dem mit Mobilfunkstationen auseinandergesetzt, äh Verfassungsschutz und Bundesnachrichtendienst äh
angesprochen. Dann hat er,
Kontrollbesuch in Bad Aibling vorgenommen, im Dezember zweitausenddreizehn, zwei Wochen vor seinem Amtsende ähm,
Entsprechend wurde er natürlich da auch behandelt. Ähm.
Dann hat er äh grundsätzliche ähm regulatorische äh Kritikpunkte äh angebracht, nämlich dass die dass das,
Aufteilung der Aufsicht in parlamentarisches Kontrollgremium. G zehn, G zehn Kommission und Datenschutzbeauftragte äh je nach Datentyp zu einer Kontrolllücke führt. Ähm also,
ne? G zehn Kommission für Verletzungen des Brief- und Fernmeldegeheimnisses, also Einschränkungen des Grundgerichtsartikels zehn äh Näheres äh regelt ein Bundesgesetz, dann das parlamentarische Kontrollgremium, dem die äh geheim,
in dem die Regierung Auskunft über die äh Geheimdienstliche Tätigkeiten gibt. Also ne,
Aber auch nur, wenn sie gefragt werden so ungefähr. Ähm und dann die Datenschutzbeauftragten, die ja sicher eher um das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz,
kümmern. Da sagt er also, diese das führt zu einer äh Verantwortungsdiffusion und zu einer Kontrolllücke.
Ich denke, das ist eine äh sehr weitsichtige ähm Analyse, die er da getätigt hat, vor allem nach Jahren seiner Tätigkeit. Ähm.
Dann sagte er, hat er sich noch zu rechtlichen Fragen geäußert, also ob ein ähm.
Quasi Transitverkehr, also Verkehr, der durch Deutschland kommt, aber von Ausland ins Ausland geht.
Ähm unter Grundrechtsschutz falle oder nicht,
Und da sagt er eben, ja, wenn das in Deutschland abgehört wird, fällt das natürlich auch unter die die Grundrechte, die in Deutschland anerkannt sind. Ähm,
Außerdem hat er klargestellt, dass Verkehrs- und Metadaten personenbezogene Daten sind und damit natürlich dem entsprechenden Datenschutzregulation unterliegen.
Und hat dann auch nochmal darauf aufmerksam gemacht, dass in Bad Aibling das BND-Gesetz auch gilt, wenn
ähm die Kommunikation mittels Satellite erhoben wird. Das war ja vor ein paar äh Wochen oder Monaten mal der Lacher, dass äh jemand von BND sagt, ich aber das hören wir doch im Weltraum ab
da gilt doch das BND-Gesetz nicht. Ja, also da hat er dann nochmal ein bisschen äh kurz äh ein paar Fnorde aufgelöst, ja.
Ähm,
Und dann sagte er, ja, wenn also die Operation Alconal äh mittels eines privatrechtlichen Vertrages zwischen BND und Telekom zustande gekommen ist, dann war das sowohl von BND als auch von der Telekom rechtswidrig. Ähm
Da geht's also dann natürlich darum, dass das Peter Schar eben nicht nur ähm.
Versteht, was moralisch in Ordnung ist und was nicht, sondern als Datenschützer natürlich seine seine Basis auf den äh auf den ähm,
Auf den rechtlichen und regulatorischen Grundsätze. Grundlagen des Datenschutzes ähm äh basiert, ne.
Also ähm ein ein interessant oder ein schöner Auftritt von Peter Schad, der da nochmal ein paar beseitigt hat.
Jo, dann gab's noch ähm eine Entscheidung des,
Amtsgericht Charlottenburg in Berlin. Das Ganze ähm hatten wir schon mal angesprochen vor einigen Ausgaben, nämlich in Ausgabe hundertneun.
Ähm da geht's dadrum, dass äh twenty Century Fox, die ja immer so ihre Leute unterwegs haben und so nach
äh Fahnen da so eine IP-Adresse äh ermittelt haben, über die angeblich ein Film getredet worden sei und der Anschlussinhaber, der dort ermittelt wurde, war halt ein Freifunnker, der halt äh sein WLAN, wie das eben bei Freifunk so ist
bereitstellt, anderen Leuten und ähm als die dann mit einer Gegenklage geantwortet haben, auf,
dieses Vorgehens äh im Übrigen in dem Fall vertreten durch die bekannte ähm Abmahn, Klitscher, Walldorf Frommer
Ähm wurde dann diese Klage auch gleich wieder zurückgezogen, allerdings wollte Waldorf Roma die Kosten nicht übernehmen. Woraufhin
Amtsgericht dann selber aktiv geworden ist in diesem Fall. Also halt klar äh wissen wollte, wer denn jetzt hier die Kosten zu tragen hat,
Ja und da gab's jetzt eine äh Entscheidung. Das ist wie gesagt jetzt nur auf Amtsgerichtsebene und hat jetzt vielleicht noch nicht so eine höhere Bedeutung, aber ist schon mal ganz interessant, dass hier eigentlich die Freifunnker einen vollen Erfolg gelandet haben auf der Ebene. Also.
Es gibt da zwar durchaus ein Rechtsschutzinteresse bei den Rechteinhabern, aber es gibt hier keinen Anspruch auf äh,
Unterlassung oder Auskunft oder Schadensersatz gegen den Anschlussinhaber,
und man könnte jetzt auch nicht automatisch mit der Vermutung daherkommen, dass äh der Anschlussinhaber jetzt hier hinter dieser Rechtsverletzung stehen würde und bezieht sich dabei auch auf.
Normalfall mehr Personenhaushalt, dass da eben auch mal andere Leute als der Anschlussinhaber den Anschluss
nutzen. Grundsätzlich wurde hier sogar gesagt, wer ein öffentliches WLAN anbietet, ist grundsätzlich als Exzessprovile einzustufen. Das ist natürlich jetzt ein sehr interessantes Statement im Hinblick auf die ganze Frage der Störerhaftung
und ähm da das jetzt nur Amtsgerichtsebene ist, muss man ja sehr zurückhaltend sein, aber grundsätzlich ist das schon mal ein ganz ganz gute äh Entscheidung.
Wenn die quasi auch über weitere Instanzen hält, dann ließe sich da sicherlich was draus machen. Man hat eh den Eindruck, dass es derzeit
bröckelt und wir hatten ja auch schon in der hundertneun berichtet, dass Freifunk da schon seit längerem auch,
aktiv geworden ist mit einer negativen Feststellungsklage, die steht noch aus,
Das heißt, diese ganzen Abmahnungen, die ihr bei Freifunk landen gegen die will sich halt frei von generell,
wären und äh sagt halt, ja wir wollen das jetzt mal festgestellt wissen,
Das ist noch offen, da gibt's noch kein Ergebnis. Jetzt gibt's halt dieses Zwischenergebnis aus äh Charlottenburg, was mit dieser negativen Feststellungsqualität Klage nicht in unmittelbaren Zusammenhang steht, aber die schon mal so ein Trend,
andeutet, dass es hier doch zumindest ein differenzierteres Denken gibt im Richterbereich.
Ja, das also dieses Denken gibt's natürlich äh immer mal wieder auch so.
Die Hoffnung müsste halt jetzt lauten, dass sich das an,
dass sich das auch wirklich mal durchsetzt. Nochmal zur Erinnerung, bei der bei dem Provider Privileg, wenn man das Gesetz.
So liest, wie es heute auch schon,
Auf dem Papier steht, dann gilt das für jeden, der anderen Zugang äh ermöglicht und das ist auch das, wie das Amtsgericht äh Charlottenburg hier äh geurteilt hat. Nur die gängige Rechtsprechung,
ähm sieht eben ähm läuft eben anders, ja? Und es man wird nicht darum herumkommen, äh diesen
diese gesamte Frage mal an auf höherer äh juristischer Ebene ein für alle Mal zu klären und das ist das, was äh Freifunk anstrengt, bestenfalls
könnte Freifunk damit die sogenannte Störerhaftung zum Fall bringen und damit den,
den Faktor,
fallen lassen, der heute Menschen daran hindert, ihr WLAN großzügig mit anderen zu teilen. Und das heißt, wenn dieser Faktor wegfällt,
dann,
Wäre eine Folge davon, dass immer mehr Menschen sich risikofrei dazu entscheiden könnten, ihre WLANs zu teilen. Und das wiederum würde dazu führen, dass Menschen,
an immer mehr Stellen problemlos Zugang zu internetfreien Wissen und Kommunikation erhalten können. Gleichzeitig.
Arbeitet Freifunk natürlich auch an technischen äh Lösungen für das Problem. Sie haben also dieses äh Freifunk VPN, das heißt, wenn du als Freifunkanbieter ähm ein ein freies WLAN,
zur Verfügung stellst, dann kannst du auch oder dann kannst du diesen Traffic durch einen VPN zu dem Oberfrei-Funk,
Knoten,
lassen, dann kommt's dort raus ins Internet und da, das hatten wir auch im äh einunddreißig C3 CC Jahresrückblick erwähnt, da haben sie jetzt auch schon den Status eines Internet Providers. Das heißt, ähm.
Wenn du,
Also da hätten sie tatsächlich könnten sie quasi ihren Reibeintrag vorweisen und sagen, wir sind hier Excess Provider, aber das Entscheidende ist hier natürlich, dass wirklich auch für
den kleinen großzügigen Bürger endlich zu ermöglichen sein Internet freizugeben.
Und diese etwas unsägliche, diese etwas unsägliche Konstrukt der äh Störerhaftung äh ein vor allem mal aus der Rechtssprechung zu verbannen.
Gut.
Dann gab's noch äh die Neuigkeit, dass äh Julia Reeder, die ähm für die Piraten ins EU-Parlament gewählte äh einzig gewählte Abgeordnete, die sich dort der,
Ähm Fraktion der Grünen angeschlossen hat, einen Entwurf zu einer Evaluation des EU-Urheberrechts vorgelegt hat.
Ich habe das nicht gelesen, muss ich dazu sagen, also habe da noch keine Zeit für gefunden. Was weißt du darüber?
Na, ich habe ihren ähm Vortrag ähm gesehen beim einunddreißigsten Copyrons. Und ich habe die Analyse von,
Leonard Dobusch äh gelesen, bei Netzpolitik Org, äh wo er äh wie war sein Wortlaut? Dieses Papier als äh die progressivste Veröffentlich,
die progressivste Veröffentlichung der EU zum Thema Urheberrecht seit Veröffentlichung des ersten Katzenbildes im Internet bezeichnet hat. Ähm.
Leonator äh der der Urheberrechtsexperte äh bei Netzpolitik Org und der Urheberrechtsexperte des Vereins digitale Gesellschaft, auf dessen Urteil ich da sehr ähm
vertraue. Ähm in dem Vortrag hat äh Julia so einige einige
Ungerechtigkeiten des Urheberrechts herausgearbeitet, aber auch natürlich so diese einige der
der Grauzonen und Unklarheiten, ja? Und was, wenn etwas auf EU-Ebene passieren soll, dann soll's ja auch immer um die Vereinigung äh äh die Vereinfachung und Vereinheitlichung ähm der Rechtssprechung in in Europa gehen. Und darauf ähm.
Zieht dieser äh,
diese Evaluation und der daraus dann irgendwann entstehende äh Entwurf für eine Änderung des Urheberrechtes äh natürlich ab.
Insbesondere, interessant ist, dass sie dann noch die Liste aller Lobbyanfragen veröffentlicht hat. Das hatte sie auch, glaube ich, schon,
bei ihrem einunddreißig zu drei Vortrag angekündigt.
Welche Anfragen.
Also wenn du Politiker bist, dann gibt es Lobbyisten.
Anfragen bei ihr. Genau. Mhm.
Genau. Also wer,
sie hat jetzt quasi Vorschläge zur Reform erstmal gemacht so das wird jetzt noch lange dauern was daraus entstehen wird. Die Richtlinie die es im Moment gibt,
Ist irgendwie vierzehn Jahre alt und äh diesen Flickenteppich möchte sie also vereinheitlichen, ne? So und jetzt hat sie äh seit seit sie angefangen hat damit zu arbeiten ähm,
haben hat sie natürlich nein, seit sie angefangen hat, dieses Thema zu bearbeiten, ähm,
Und seit sich herausgestellt hat, dass sie da jetzt auch aktiv werden würde und äh auch mit äh mit.
Quasi mit mit,
gestärktem Rücken sich diesem Thema widmen würde haben sich natürlich die Lobbyanfragen an sie irgendwie verxacht und alle Gesprächstermine, die sie da jetzt wahrgenommen hat, hat sie äh eben auch auf ihrer
Seite veröffentlicht.
Und ich meine, dass äh meine mich zu erinnern, dass sie in ihrem Vortrag auch schon so ähm ja, dass äh also das sieht man auch in ihrer Veröffentlichung und in ihrem Vortrag hatte sie das auch schon so ähm.
Quasi hat sie in so einem Tortendiagramm aufgemalt, sind das jetzt rechte Inhaber, sind das Autoren? Äh sind das Diensteanbieter, Forscher, Nutzer,
die mich da anfragen und dann hat sie entsprechend.
Jetzt veröffentlicht in welcher äh wie sie prozentual diese ähm diese Gesprächsangebote auch wahrgenommen hat.
Okay, das heißt, man weiß im Vorfeld schon, mit wem wird sie sich treffen und wie sind diese Personen überhaupt auch einzuordnen.
Vorfeld. Ich glaube, das ist schon jetzt eher,
im Nachhinein, da müsste ich jetzt, ja, also es genau, da hat sie, ja, ja, das sind Daten, äh, eben im November, September und so, der vergangenen, des vergangenen Jahres,
Ja, geht soweit zurück, wie in den Juli. Ja, da hat sie also ihren Kalender einfach mal äh.
Äh publiziert und hat hat das statistisch äh eben auch ausgewertet.
Mit wem sie sich da wie getroffen hat und ähm so. Das ist, wenn man das mal so schön sagen darf, ähm natürlich ähm.
Best of äh Piratenpartei äh Prinzipien, ne. Also so hat man sich das ja auch immer erhofft, gewünscht und vorgestellt bei der Piratenpartei, äh dass sie äh ihre Politik transparent gestalten.
Innovativ gestalten.
Und ähm da kann man jetzt äh mal schauen, wie wie gut das vielleicht, wenn es immerhin nur eine Einzelperson ist, die hat natürlich den Vorteil, dass sie ähm.
Sich nicht mit den anderen Piraten rumärgern muss, die er immer bemüht zu sein, scheinen den Karren irgendwie in den Dreck zu ziehen. Ähm wieder jetzt eine Einzelperson mal äh ordentlich einer konkreten Aufgabe nach äh kommen kann,
Das wird sicherlich spannend in nächster Zeit zu beobachten.
So, letzter Punkt TTIP.
Ja, TTIP, wollen wir in der nächsten Folge nochmal äh tiefer behandeln. Aber äh es gab jetzt eine sehr schöne Meldung, dass nämlich der Verfassungsrechtler Siegfried Proos, die,
Idee der privaten Schiedsgerichte, von denen ich in der letzten Woche schon berichtet habe
in den Freihandelsabkommen äh CETA und TTIP als einen Verstoß gegen deutsches Verfassungs- und EU-Recht sowie ein Systembruch des Völkerrechtes hält.
Also ihr sagt, das ist so in in nichts, was wir jemals irgendwie heilig gehalten haben äh äh als Demokratie,
passt das passt das irgendwie noch rein? Und das.
Also er hat schon sein Laserschwert gezückt, muss man jetzt mal dazu sagen, weil er ist ja nicht nur Verfassungsrechtler, sondern er war auch über zehn Jahre lang äh Richter im
Bundesverfassungsgericht, also es ist jetzt auch nicht irgendjemand, sondern ist auch jemand, der eben sehr wohl
gesprochen hat für das äh Verfassungsgericht und da sicherlich eine fundierte äh Meinung hat.
Dementsprechend wurde das auch mit Interesse äh wiedergegeben in den Medien. In dem Fall beziehen wir uns vor allem auf einen Artikel äh der S Z,
an der Stelle, wo ich mal die SZ mal äh loben möchte für ein,
Stil, den sie vor einiger Zeit eingeführt haben, dass sie solche Artikel, ich weiß gar nicht, ob's fast alle sind, aber zumindest ein Paar, auf die ich jetzt hier auch verlinkt habe äh diese Woche. Immer mit so mit so beginnt.
Also da kommt sozusagen erstmal so ein so ein Management-Hamory und dann kommt eigentlich erst der Artikel. Das finde ich ein,
sehr angenehmen Style. Also das hilft schon sehr, um mal schnell so die wesentlichen Talking Points äh überhaupt zur Kenntnis zu nehmen, um dann auch noch genug Futter zu haben, da tiefer einzusteigen.
Sehr schön. Aber egal. TTIP wird auf jeden Fall von ihm als äh extrem kritisch, beziehungsweise all diese sogenannten Freihandelsabkommen,
werden als sehr kritisch ähm bewertet, schlicht und ergreifend, weil das ja auch eine äh Sache, die wir hier letzte Woche diskutiert haben
diese Schiedsgerichte eine private äh Angelegenheit sind zwischen Anwälten letzten Endes, die halt quasi jegliche äh lokale Nationale oder supranationale Juristik
aushebeln können und das dann auch tun. Wofür sie auch angelegt sind, genau das zu tun.
Ja, aber um um diese,
um diese Abkommen vor einem äh Bundes äh verfassungsrecht oder vor dem Europäischen Gerichtshof scheitern lassen zu können, müsstest du dir erstmal einsehen,
und das ist ja schon Teil eins des Spiels, dass ähm,
der Inhalt dieser Abkommen eben vor der Öffentlichkeit geheim gehalten werden soll und was ich was ich glaube, ist ja, dass sie eher versuchen würden ähm,
den Regierungen Möglichkeiten der Einflussnahme,
auf die politischen Entscheidungen,
gegen die geklagt wird, geben zu können, auf dass dann die Regierung, nachdem sie im Geheimen am Schiedsgericht verurteilt wurde oder eine Strafe angedroht bekommen hat, ähm einfach investorenfreundlich Einfluss nehmen kann,
Also um das jetzt mal auf die maximale Verschwörungsebene zu heben.
Aber auch das wäre natürlich verfassungsrechtlich bedenklich.
Äh auf jeden Fall der Boss hat äh jetzt nicht nur gesagt, dass er das alles doof findet, sondern er hat da auch ähm im Auftrag der äh Hans-Böckler-Stiftung.
Die gilt als gewerkschaftsnah, welcher Gewerkschaft?
Allen Gewerkschaften nah. Ähm er hat also eine Studie erstellt, die nächste Woche veröffentlicht wird und da werden wir dann wahrscheinlich weitere Details sehen und dann wird das bestimmt noch mal,
einen Nachschlag geben mit dieser Geschichte, ne. Also das ist äh interessant. Er meint dann übrigens auch sagt er das oder sagt das nur der Artikel.
Deutschland ja diese Investoren, Schutzregeln irgendwie, dass das sozusagen ein Konzept ist, was von Deutschland auf den Tisch gelegt wurde im Rahmen dieser Verhandlung.
Naja, die die gibt's ja schon länger. Also die muss Deutschland nicht im Rahmen dieser Verhandlung schon, sondern irgendwann mal früher sich.
Nicht im Rahmen dieser, sondern erwähnt ja hier auch hundertdreißig laufende Freihandelsabkommen, die im Bestand sind, wurde sozusagen schon irgendwie ein Teil davon ist.
Noch kurz zur Hans-Böckler-Stiftung Hans-Böckler war der erste Vorsitzende des Deutschen Gewerkschaftsbundes und entsprechend ist die Hans-Böckler-Stiftung äh auch quasi ein Organ des deutschen Gewerkschaftsbundes DGB.
Wieder was gelernt. Gut, das bringt uns als.
Tim, du warst nie so der der Arbeitskämpfer, ne? Nicht so der nicht so der proletarische.
Bin äh ja den Strukturen nicht groß geworden.
Ist kein Proletarier.
Ich würde mich noch nicht mal als ausgesprochen politischen Menschen bezeichnen.
Später Einsicht in der hundertneunundzwanzigsten Folge. Politik, also sorry, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das.
Ich will nur ehrlich sein, aber ich gebe mir Mühe.
Politik für, ach nee, nee, den Song darf man nicht nehmen. Okay. Wir fischen am A-Politischer Rand.
Tun wir das.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, man bemüht sich halt so, tut was man kann.
Sagte, nö, ich meine, ach so, ja, da ähm ich dachte, wir machen noch so einen Ausklang, nachdem wir uns jetzt hier schon äh bei bei dem bei den Themen der der Nazis und der Demonstration gegen Nazis äh so,
auf dünnes Eis bewegt haben.
Auf dünnen Eis. Willst du noch ein Wort haben?
Norbert Norbert Schramm Award für besonders Touretten auf dünnem Eis.
Ah okay, ja. Hm. Den ähm Felix von Leitner Award für besonders diplomatische Ausführungen oder sowas.
Lass mir das. Willst du noch Dank aussprechen? Ja.
Ja dem dem Christian möchte ich an dieser Stelle natürlich herzlich danken, das weiß er ja,
und ähm natürlich auch äh den Hörern, die uns jetzt entgegen Tims Willen für alle möglichen Awards,
vorschlagen. Aber ich möchte eigentlich nur hochdotierte Preise. Also sowas wie ein Friedensnobelpreis,
Ach nee, der ist ja der ist, wir müssen wissenschaftlichen, was ist denn der höchstsortierte Preis? Warte mal, den den wollen wir haben. Höchst dotierter Preis. Google.
Höchstsortierter Kunst? Oh!
Guck mal, es gibt es gibt sehr schöne höchst dotierte Preise, die äh für die wir uns noch qualifizieren können.
Ja, was denn?
Den höchstsortierten Kunstpreis.
Was das turner Preis.
Das ist der japanische Kunstpreis Premium Imperiale.
So, den könnten wir doch mal. Ich finde, den würden wir.
Was? Premium Imperiale.
Emium, Imperiale, japanischer Kunstpreis. Ähm die goldene Chöre höchster Deutschland höchste Täterpreis für Kinder und Jugendbeteiligung.
Der höchst dotierte deutsche Forschungspreis.
Das ist der äh von der DFG wird der verliehen zweieinhalb Millionen.
Also im Premium Imperiale gibt's äh sozusagen Weltkulturpreis zum Gedenken an seine Hoheit, Prinz äh Takamazo. Und das ist doch eigentlich sehr schön, dann schließen wir ja einfach diese Sendung mit einem Gedenken an seine Hoheit Prinz Taramazo.
Auf Wiederhören.
Bis bald.